c'est l'heure de journal de l'afrique
soyez les bienvenus sur france 24 à la
une ce soir une date un anniversaire
celui de la chute d'alpha condé et du
coup d'état en guinée quel bilan pour
les militaires après un an au pouvoir
qu'en pensent les guinéens qui
attendaient beaucoup des nouveaux
dirigeants reportage à conakry et
décryptage dans ce journal avec 6 dyane
scène est journaliste indépendant et
spécialiste de la guinée
le mali qui libère 3b soldat ivoirien
détenu sur son territoire depuis le 10
juillet il s'agit de trois femmes libéré
pour des raisons humanitaires 46 soldats
ivoiriens sont toujours détenus au mali
les négociations pour leur libération
sont toujours en cours où nous serons à
abidjan dans ce journal et puis ce soir
on vous parle du sommet sur l'adoption
l'adaptation pardon de l'afrique au
changement climatique il se tient ce
lundi à rotterdam aux pays bas
l'occasion pour nous de vous emmener au
sénégal où les autorités ont décidé
d'avoir recours aux ogm en réponse aux
conséquences des changements climatiques
sur les rendements agricoles mais vous
allez voir qu'ils sont nombreux à s'y
opposer reportage à suivre
c'était le 5 septembre 2021 le président
alpha condé a été délogé par des
militaires à conakry le colonel
doumbouya a pris le pouvoir promettant
une transition rapide et un transfert du
pouvoir aux civils
les guinéens ne voyait pas forcément ce
coup d'état d'un mauvais oeil la de la
mauvaise gouvernance et souvent hostiles
au troisième mandat d'alpha condé qu'en
est il aujourd'hui qu'en est il de leurs
attentes de leurs espoirs nos
correspondants en guinée malik diakité
et sarah sakho sont allés à leur
rencontre reportage
la question divise et passionne à la
fois en guinée dans un café de la
capitale ce groupe d'amis ne se lasse
pas de débattre du bilan des militaires
arrivée au pouvoir il ya tout juste un
an entre enthousiasme et des illusions
les avis divergent
bienvenue ils ont lancé ce qu'on appelle
elle va chanter de récupération des
domaines de l'état ça s'était très bien
la moralisation de l'amsa son public à
travers la création de la cour dé
répression des infractions économiques
et financières
ça aussi c'était très bien nous sommes
assis nous sommes figés
nous sommes devenus comme une porte rien
mais bouge donc je dirais que
l'avènement du cndd b à la tête de notre
pays je ne parlerai même pas depuis
vingt sept ans briguerait accueillis
dans un soulagement général le colonel
mamadou doumbouya fait désormais face à
de nombreuses critiques
les manifestations ont éclaté
dernièrement à l'appel de l'opposition
et de la société civile leurs partisans
dénoncent une confiscation du pouvoir
l'interdiction de manifester la
répression des opposants et une
instrumentalisation de la justice
cet homme politique avait applaudi
l'arrivée du cnrd il mobilise
aujourd'hui ses troupes pour protester
contre la durée de la transition les
transhumants ont été imposées aux
peuples usine alors que la transition se
taillent mandat la transition ne doit
pas dépasser points 15 au 18 mois c'est
pour vous dire encore une fois ils ont
l'intention de ces mesures au pouvoir
mais le peuple va s'opposer le
gouvernement de son côté défend son
bilan et assure que la transition suit
normalement son cours de charte a été
publiée
au conseil national de transition qui
fait office d'assemblée nationale est en
place et pour recevoir des cadres et une
administration qui est très largement
aujourd'hui des pronesti un an après
l'arrivée des militaires le dialogue
politique et de nouveau au point mort en
guinée une mission de la cédéao est en
cours pour tenter de sortir de l'impasse
pour en parler avec nous ce soir si
diane lane et journaliste indépendant et
spécialiste de la guinée merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous sur ce plateau pour
sommer alors vous avez vue avait on
avait regardé ensemble ce reportage
peut-on dire que c'est la désillusion
aujourd'hui en guinée après sept années
après la prise de pouvoir des militaires
la déligitimation elle vient surtout pas
du fait simplement du seul cnrd mais que
c'est la troisième fois dans les 64 ans
dans 1 dans un mois on fait la 64 ème
année d'indépendance 64 ans
d'indépendance que la guinée vite des
coups d'état militaires jamais
d'internet dans les règles de l'art
constitutionnel quoi donc là c'est
l'histoire qui bégaie et malheureusement
cnrd kiwis à se libérer d'une certaine
manière des guides d'alpha condé un vrai
dictateur mais répète les erreurs du
passé à savoir qu'on dirige nous on sait
ce qu'on fait laissez-nous faire faites
nous confiance et ses 36 mois de
transition je pense pas que ça le vrai
problème c'est qu'on ne sait pas
vraiment c'est quoi l'agenda quoi en
faire cette transition en 36 mois et on
s'aime pas partir de quand est ce que sa
part de 5 septembre le renversement
d'alpha condé est ce que c'est quand
mais ce doublé a été investi président
est ce que quand il a annoncé les 36
mois donc c'est le flou en fait je pense
qu'il la pêche dans cette gente alors ce
nouveau pouvoir militaire a eu une sorte
de période d'essai les guinéens laurent
laisser leur chance peut-on dire
aujourd'hui que cette période est finie
tant que la junte remonte pas femme ne
doit pas des gages de transparence et de
confiance en disant on va faire
différemment des autres bah oui il a
effectivement les guinéens sont pas
stupides il y en a certains flamands qui
aime beaucoup à mamadou doumbia le
colonel le président colonel mais par
contre on connaît l'histoire écrit
militaire c'est pas nouveau si vous
voulez pour les guinéens donc l'histoire
se répète et même un peu gamin de 15 ans
vous expliquera que s'il a déjà vécu en
quelque sorte tout là que ses parents
ont vécu donc là le problème c'est que
la junte ne montre pas de signe réel une
véritable volonté de changement réel il
n'y a pas de date vraiment véritablement
fort malgré la création d'une cour de
répression des crimes économiques des
pays mm qui sont en prison ça c'est
assez nouveau d'accord mais il faut
aller beaucoup plus loin ça soit simple
en cas de la cosmétique pour de nombreux
guinéens qui voit effectivement on l'a
vu dans ses mots dans ce reportage ce
monsieur qui dit le pays est figé mais
il est figé depuis 64 ans maintenant
alors justement vous parlez de la
transition la durée de la transition
cette question est régulièrement posée
par le fn décès le front national la
défense de la constitution ses membres
affirment que les militaires veulent
rester au pouvoir à ce qu'un avis qu un
risque parce que le fn et c'est là
dessus oui à une à un argument parce que
c'est vrai qu'il ya eu cet acte fort
cette ligne forte lorsque le président
doumbouya a donc lu à la télévision
l'achat de la transition après avoir
pris le pouvoir en disant très vite les
membres de transition ne peuvent pas se
compter aux élections mais c'est vrai
qu'il a fondé sa raison on ne sait pas
réellement qui sont ses membres en cas
dans la junte on sait qu'il est mon kilt
qui composent le cnt le gouvernement
mais on ne sait pas xe et xixe est
exactement qui composent cette junte et
ça c'est important parce que mettre un
faux nez ça ça arrive tout le temps et
donc l'argument est assez fort
transparence je pense pas qu'ils sont de
gestion et de transparence dans qu'est
ce qu'on compte faire de ce pays et
qu'est ce que mon compte réinventer le
guinéen alors les nouvelles autorités
ont rapidement procédé à l'interdiction
des rassemblements et des manifestations
il ya eu plusieurs morts cet été suite à
des affrontements entre les jeunes et
les forces de l'ordre y at il un risque
de flambées de violence est ce que c'est
vraiment à craindre aujourd'hui même
temps que le cnrd ne montre pas des
gages là il ya quelques la semaine
dernière ait eu un rapport d qui a été
remis au président sur des assises
nationales qui sont tenues entre mars et
avril mais là encore c'est pareil on est
en baisse à ceux déjà été fait
auparavant sous alpha condé ne se lancer
à compter avant lui et le cic assists
ont rassemblé des dizaines de milliers
de personnes à travers le pays il aurait
fallu mettre à la télévision impliquer
le peuple guinéen qui centre pour une
fois acteur de son avenir il aurait
fallu rendre ce rapport public ce n'est
pas le cas donc on a vraiment
l'impression qu'ils font ce qu'ils
veulent et c'est ça en fait le risque
c'est pas les morts c'est toujours
regrettable mais des quêtes
manifestations mais heureusement guinée
s'il ya des morts mais c'est vraiment ce
cette incapacité à faire à faire preuve
de transparence et surtout d'impliquer
tous les guinéennes et guinéens merci
beaucoup en tout cas à sidi en scène et
pour votre décryptage rappelle que cette
journaliste indépendant et spécialiste
de la guinée merci beaucoup
un geste humanitaire c'est l'argument
avancé par les autorités à malienne qui
ont décidé de libérer trois femmes
soldats ivoirienne au total 46 soldats
sont toujours détenus sur le territoire
malien ils y sont inculpés depuis le 10
juillet pour atteinte à la sûreté de
l'état bamako les accuse d'être
mercenaires les autorités ivoiriennes
quant à elle affirme qu'ils avaient été
envoyés en mission pour la minus ma la
correspondance à abidjan de ces diamants
jo
il était donc 21 heures à abidjan ce
samedi lorsque l'avion des trois seules
dates ivoirienne a atterré elles ont pu
retrouver leurs proches après plus d'un
mois et demi de détention à bamako elles
sont désormais libres puisque le mali ne
les considèrent plus comme des
mercenaires mais ce n'est pas le cas des
46 autres soldats toujours en détention
à bamako pour atteinte à la sûreté de
l'état du côté d'abidjan on se veut
optimiste
l'état major a fait savoir que les
négociations menées par le togo continue
un optimisme partagé par le président de
la transition du burkina faso en visite
officielle à abidjan ce lundi il se dit
confiant pour lui le mali la côte
d'ivoire et le burkina faso ont tout
intérêt à s'entendre pour lutter contre
la menace terroriste dans la région les
négociations continuent donc mais reste
qu'à ce jour aucune information précise
n'a filtré concernant l'issue ni le
contenu de ces négociations
on en vient à ce sommet sur l'adaptation
de l'afrique au changement climatique il
se tient ce lundi à rotterdam aux pays
bas la rencontre qui réunit les chefs
d'états et des gouvernements devraient
contribuer à accélérer le déblocage des
25 milliards de dollars
d'investissements d'ici 2025 une somme
qui devrait permettre au continent de
mieux contrôler sa vulnérabilité
climatique
je vous propose d'écouter macky sall le
président du sénégal et président en
exercice de l'union africaine au micro
de marc perelman et alix le bourdon
donc besoin de 25 milliards de dollars
sur cinq ans si on ne le fait pas
l'afrique fera comme les autres
malheureusement pas d'eux aura recours
aux énergies fossiles charbon
gaz
je pense que c'est nous tous qui le
paieront ce sur la planète or les
africains veulent aller dans
l'adaptation mais à condition qu'elle
soit financée connaissant quelques les
africaines et une énergie pour leurs
populations
et on part justement sénégal où les et
aux autorités ont décidé de miser sur
les ogm les organise génétiquement
modifié une réponse aux conséquences des
changements climatiques sur les
rendements agricoles sauf que les ogm ne
séduise absolument pas tous ceux qui se
battent pour l'environnement parmi eux
des agriculteurs nos correspondants sont
allés à la rencontre de ceux qui sont
vent debout contre les ogm reportages
des limes ndao et sarah sakho
aïssatou est la spécialiste des semences
dans cette ferme agri écologique située
à une centaine de kilomètres à l'est de
dakar
hélas beaucoup d'appréhension depuis le
vote de la nouvelle loi qui autorise
l'utilisation des cultures ogm au
sénégal elle crée une dépendance aux
semences génétiquement modifiées et la
disparition des fertilisants
traditionnel c'est la possibilité amap à
celle là où je suis allé à produire des
semences paysannes qui sans être de
productive des années durant cet om là à
la possibilité de croiser ma valise
était temps a passé et dans ce cas je
n'aurais plus cette pureté variétale que
c'était que jamais avant dans mon stock
et la semence maintenant à la langue
dans la durabilité bien sûr elle va
finir par mu t elle va finir par
développer d'autres jeunes qui ne sont
pas propres à ma pauvre variété rahim a
créé cette ferme il y a cinq ans il
enseigne à des étudiants les méthodes
d'agriculure j il faut une bonne
rotation culturale et la rotation
culturale nous a permis de mettre en
place une légumineuse les semences ogm
produisent des rendements élevés à court
terme mais leur productivité diminue
considérablement avec le temps pour la
rime les ogm auront des conséquences
désastreuses à long terme l'agriculteur
qui utilisent les josé m parce que c'est
ça qui nous lie le monde là ça peut au
début ni le monde mais à la longue c'est
pas l'agriculture durable et maintenant
la réponse c'est l'agriculture durable
qui l agro écologique qui nous permette
de pouvoir être souverain d'être
autonome et d'autres insécurité
critiqué par l'opposition et plusieurs
organisations de la société civile le
gouvernement pense que les organismes
génétiquement modifiés sont la meilleure
réponse d'adaptation au changement
climatique
malgré à plusieurs sollicitations le
ministère de l'environnement n'a pas
donné suite à nos demandes d'interview
voilà c'est la fin de journal de
l'afrique restez avec nous dans quelques
instants la suite de paris direct avec
audry racing
[Musique]